ça y est c'est l'anniversaire de
Castaldi ah oui et en fait il a ils ont
fait un anniversaire surprise j'étais le
seul être invité
de l'équipe
papa le seul mais c'est votre femme
toi tu dis même pas bon anniversaire
avec qui avec moi
vous êtes un proche
mon ami connard ah mais c'est beau
franchement
et tout n'est pas comme toi excuse-moi
le jour j'ai plus d'oser que tu vas plus
parler connard
s
tu peux pas récupérer mon mec il est
tout seul et puis il a pas d'appartement
et moi je dis viens chez moi ce connard
au frigo et pour les bagnoles et dans
mon lit je te jure
même pas un cadeau rien zéro d'accord
alors alors pardon l'appartement était
d'une bulgarité
la salle de bain la salle de bain c'est
une espèce de jacuzzi ou les lumières
changé et jaune vert rouge avec des
bulles de partout tout était laid
c'était moi je me sentais pas bien
dedans
[Musique]
quelque chose moi je suis à fond qui me
Casta ah ouais alors
six mois non je suis resté trois mois je
me suis va très bien qu'une fois j'étais
en plein soleil
allez merci merci les gars allez vous
vous ferez le cul et vous verrez tout ça